what's going on everybody and welcome to
a review slash overview of the new
Nvidia Jetson
nano dev kit now historically these dev
kits have been on the more expensive
side like 200 to 400 dollars or even
more than that but the Nano comes in at
$99 which in my opinion approaches more
of the general hobbyist or the type of
person who might be buying raspberry
pies instead and what you're getting for
this $99 is pretty darn awesome so first
of all what are we getting so the
biggest thing that we're getting here
over say a Raspberry Pi is a 128 core
Maxwell GPU also you're getting a quad
core arm CPU you've got 4 gigabytes of
RAM micro SD storage you've got 4 USB
3.0 ports you've got tons of GPIO here
you've got a CSI connector here four
cameras so something like the Raspberry
Pi camera also you can just use USB
cameras of course we've got gigabit
internets
we've got HDMI display ports you've got
a 5 volt 4 amp in here you can also
actually power this board via micro USB
can't imagine why you buy this board for
anything that would allow you to use
that low of power but hey it's there for
you if you have that use so first of all
you know this thing is called nano so I
feel like I probably need to address the
size of the board so I have here not a
Raspberry Pi 4 but it's the same size
it's a Raspberry Pi 3 so you can kind of
see how these compare in size obviously
due to this heatsink it's actually
considerably
considerably taller although most people
do wind up putting something on their
their processor there but you actually
don't have to with a PI I'm going to
talk about that in a second here with
the Nano so it's a considerably taller
and it's about me it's less than double
the size of a pie but it's it's close to
double the size of the pine but where it
gets more interesting is comparing it to
sizes of the old board
so for example this is a tk1 so a really
old dev kit board but you can see here
it's considerably smaller than even this
board which was actually one of the
smaller ones and then in comparison I
don't have one but the TX one in the TX
two I've just drawn out here so here's
our little baby Nano and then you've got
your TK 1 and then the TX one in two
sizes for comparison so quite small can
definitely be used in a lot of
applications because of it so let's talk
briefly about heat so traditionally with
raspberry PI's I've kind of abused them
I don't really cool down the processor
in any way I never put fans or a little
I've seen people with the little heat
sinks it's cute it's adorable it's not
necessary I've used raspberry PI's in
very hot blistering conditions they are
really robust boards they're totally
fine
but I will I mean ok I have killed my
fair share of raspberry PI's don't get
me wrong but the raspberry pi is a very
Hardy board now when it comes to the
Nano I don't know if it's just because
the GPU runs hotter or what even
including this gigantic heatsink you
still have to have a fan you just do if
at least if you're using that GPU which
is kind of odd because historically all
of the dev kits side this is the only
one I have but they've all come with
fans I'll put up some pictures if I
remember to of the TX one and TX 2 but
they have heat sinks but then there's
like a recessed fan in there
I really wish they would have just done
that to this board I don't know if it's
a cost-savings thing or what but I
strongly advise that you get some sort
of extra cooling so I'm thinking maybe
some sort of water-based solution you
know ok I'm just kidding but definitely
some sort of bigger heatsink or
something like that ok but seriously you
definitely want one of these like little
fans or something like that that you can
put on or a case that has a fan you'd
need to be moving air if this thing is
just sitting here this heatsink heats up
it get it's like burning to the touch
and within about
I would say it took about 15 minutes I
was running an object detection model
and in about 15 minutes I fraught the
board just like turned off the SD card
got corrupted and I had to like remount
the image and all that it was it was a
really fun but this thing was super hot
like using a really advanced temperature
sensor called my thumb it was too hot to
the touch which is generally a bad thing
for especially when it's the heatsink
that is hot to the touch because this is
distributing heat over this entire
heatsink which I promise you is not the
size of your CPU or your GPU so yeah big
deal be really careful about the heat
and just by a fan or use a case with a
fan or whatever all right so now what I
want to do is you show you guys a quick
example of doing object detection on
this board we are quite literally going
to grab tensorflow put it on here run
the tensorflow
object detection API and see what we get
and then the other thing I'd like to do
is show you guys one of the newer
technologies from an video called tensor
R T and when we get there I'll explain a
little bit more about it so let's check
it out alright as silly as I feel
recording physically the monitor what
we're looking to get here is an actual
frame rate for the object detection
model and if I was using something like
OBS to record the screen that would be
skewing results considerably so what you
see here is straight tensor flow GPU
we're running the tensor flow object
detection API and we're using the
inception v2 model as you can see here
we're getting 1.3 frames per second with
one object detected the more objects
that you detect that's going to impact
framerate so we definitely want to
compare either with zero objects which i
think is kind of silly or one object at
least or more so for here we're just
going to compare with one object at a
time anyway you can see 1.3 frames per
second now most people would be like
whoa okay but shouldn't you be running
TF light and not regular full-blown
tensorflow on such a tiny device and
that's probably true so now let me go
ahead and set up for
you have light okay and here we have the
TF light example again using the
inception v2 model and what we have here
in this case is somewhere between 4 &
4.1 frames per second so a considerable
improvement I mean you can see I'm just
moving this pin around just for example
of frame rate I mean that's not terrible
I should have done that under one frames
per second but at 1 frame per second the
problem is basically your reactions and
the things that you're seeing could be
delayed by an entire second which is
pretty pretty hefty so in this case
we're seeing four frames per second so
not too bad that's borderline dare I say
acceptable now let's show the tensor or
T version so here we have the tensor our
T version of Inception v2 it's getting
on average like 9.5 frames per second
it's fluctuating from the upper eighths
to even 10 frames a second so I'm gonna
call it 9.5 and that should be fair I
think so compared that to say the the TF
light it's about twice as fast and then
raw tensorflow GPU it's like nine times
faster so that's pretty cool
so I'll just push his pen back and forth
so you can see you know I wouldn't want
to play a game at this frames per second
but it's fairly reactive so again this
is all done using tensor RT which is an
optimization that we can apply at the
like basically once we've got our frozen
tensor flow graph we can use tensor RT
to further optimize and hopefully speed
up significantly inference which
basically that's when we're doing our
predictions so it's not going to help us
speed up training or anything like that
but in terms of actually using it in
practice
it can be considerably faster than what
you might just get via just your vanilla
output and dot predicts so really really
cool stuff I hope to actually look into
tents rrt much more in the future so for
example with like the self-driving car
and Grand Theft Auto the more frames per
second we could get
the performance would increase like like
considerably like if we go from 30
frames a second to like 45 made a huge
difference so seeing improvements like
this really excites me so I don't really
want to look more into tents or RT into
the future but also pretty cool to see
it helping out this little nano 2 object
detection finally do an object detection
on the nano I just chose inception v2
it's a decent model feel free to try a
different model if you want I definitely
this is not the quickest model to run on
a small little device like this so you
can definitely get way better frames for
a second more you can get for sure like
30 frames 40 frames plus but this is an
actually pretty accurate model that
you're not going to get either miss a
lot of things or get the wrong
classification and stuff questions
comments concerns whatever feel free to
leave them below to come join us in the
discord that's discord GG / syntax
otherwise I will see you in another
video
this video was brought to you in part by
the following amazing channel members
Rhydian Edwards Mike Smith AJ Shanice
Antony bhowmick Kyle Gunn be the dragon
5 7 3 source Roca s all with us for a
month now as well as Colonel Magoo Khan
Ian Kristensen vissa Rajkumar why you
Michelle Berardi with us for two months
and finally Drac adducts uma Kampf Sam
or three months thank you all very much
for your support helps me put out
awesome videos like this for awesome
people like you